the idea that
technology is values neutral values
agnostic
and people can use it for constructive
or destructive purposes
but it doesn't predispose anything it's
just
it's just silly naive technology
elicits patterns of human behavior
because those who utilize it and get
ahead
end up behaving differently because of
their utilization of it and then
other people then they end up shaping
the world or other people race to also
get the power of the
technology and so there's whole schools
of anthropology that look at the
effect on social systems and the minds
of people of the change in our tooling
marvin harris's work called cultural
materialism looked at this deeply
obviously uh marshall mcluhan looked
specifically at the way that information
technologies changed the nature of our
beliefs minds values
social systems
i will not try to do this rigorously
because there are academics we'll
disagree on the subtle details but i'll
do it kind of like illustratively
you think about the emergence of the
plow the oxtron plow in the beginning of
agriculture that came with it where
before that you had hunter gather
and then you had horticulture kind of a
digging stick but not
the plow well that the world changed a
lot with that right
and
a few of the changes that um at least
some theorists believe in
is when the oxtron plow started to
proliferate any culture that utilized it
was able to start to actually cultivate
grain because just
with a digging stick you couldn't get
enough grain for it to matter grain was
a storable caloric surplus they could
make it through the famines they could
grow their population so the ones that
used it got so much ahead that it became
obligate and everybody
used it that corresponding with the use
of a plow
animism went away everywhere that it
existed because you can't talk about the
spirit of the buffalo while beating the
cow all day long to
pull a plow so the moment that we do
animal husbandry of that kind we have to
beat the cow all day you have to say
it's just a dumb animal man has dominion
over earth and the nature of even our
religious and spiritual ideas change
you went from women primarily using the
digging stick to do the horticulture
or gathering before that men doing the
hunting stuff to now men had to use the
plow because the upper body strength
actually really mattered women would
have miscarriages when they would do it
when they were pregnant
so all the caloric supply started to
come from men where it had been from
both before
and the ratio of male female gods
changed to being mostly male gods
following that
um obviously we went from very s
that particular line of thought then
also says that feminism followed the
tractor
and that the rise of feminism um
in the west has started to follow women
being able to say we can do what men
can because the male upper body strength
wasn't differential once the internal
combustion engine was much stronger
um and we can drive a tractor so
i don't think to try to trace complex
things to one cause is a good idea so i
think this is a reductionist view but it
has truth in it
and so the idea that technology is
values agnostic is silly
technology codes patterns of behavior
that code rationalizing those patterns
of behavior and believing in them
the plow also is the beginning of the
anthropocene right it was the beginning
of us changing the environment radically
to
to clear-cut areas to just make them
useful for people which also meant the
change of the
view of where the the web of life were
just a part of it etc so
all those types of things um so that's
brilliantly put
but by the way that was just brilliant
but the question is so it's not agnostic
but so we have to look at what the
psychological effects of specific tech
applied certain ways
are and be able to say it's not just
doing the first order thing you intended
it's doing like the effect on patriarchy
and animism
and the end of tribal culture in the
beginning of empire and the class
systems that came with that
we can go on and on about what the plow
did um the beginning of surplus was
inheritance which then became the
capital model and like lots of things
so we have to say when we're looking at
the tech how is
what are the values built into the way
the tech is being built that are not
obvious
right so you always have to consider
externalities yes and the externalities
are not just physical to the environment
they're also to how the people are being
conditioned and how the relationality
between them
question i'm asking you so i personally
would rather be
led by a plow and a tractor than stalin
okay
that's the question i'm asking you is uh
in creating an emergent government
or people where there's a democracy
that's dynamic
that makes choices that does governance
at
at like a very kind of liquid
like uh there's a bunch of fine
resolution layers of abstraction
of governance happening at all scales
right and doing so dynamically where no
one person has power at any one time
that can dominate
and impose rule okay that's the stalin
version
i'm saying isn't there the
uh alter the isn't the alternative
that's emergent
empowered or made possible by
the plow and the tractor which is the
modern version of that
is like the internet the the digital
space where we can
the monetary system where you have the
cryptocurrency and so on
but you have much more importantly to me
at least is just basic social
interaction the mechanisms of human
transacting with each other in the space
of ideas isn't
so yes it's not agnostic definitely not
agnostic
you've had a brilliant rant there the
tractor has effects
but isn't that the way we achieve an
emergent system
of uh governance yes but i wouldn't say
we're on track
you haven't seen anything promising
sometimes i haven't seen anything
promising is that to be on track
requires understanding and guiding some
of the things differently than is
currently happening and it's possible
that's actually what i really care about
so
you couldn't have had a stalin without
having certain
technologies emerge he couldn't have
ruled such a big area without
transportation technologies without
the train without the communication tech
that made it possible
so when you say you'd rather have a
tractor or a plow than a stall and
there's a relationship between them that
is more recursive
which is new physical technologies
allow rulers to rule with more power
over larger distances
historically and
um but some things are more responsible
for that than others
like stalin also ate stuff for breakfast
but the thing he ate for breakfast
is less responsible for the starvation
of millions
than than the train the train is more
responsible for that
and then the weapons of war are more
responsible so some technology
like let's not throw it all in the
you're saying like
technology has a responsibility here but
some is
better than others i'm saying that
people's use of technology will change
their behavior so it has behavioral
dispositions built in
the change of the behavior will also
change the values in the society
it's very complicated right it will also
as a result
both make people who have different
kinds of predispositions with regard to
rulership
and different kinds of new capacities
and so
we have to think about these things it's
kind of well
understood that the printing press and
then in early industrialism ended
feudalism
and created kind of nation states so one
thing i would say
as a long trend that we can look at is
that whenever there is a
step function a major leap in technology
physical technology
the the underlying techno-industrial
base with which we do stuff
it ends up coding for it ends up
predisposing a whole bunch of human
behavioral patterns that the previous
social system what had not emerged to
try to solve
and so it usually ends up breaking the
previous social systems the way the plow
broke the tribal system the way that the
industrial revolution broke the feudal
system
and then new social systems have to
emerge they can deal with that
the new powers the new dispositions
whatever with that tech
obviously the nuke broke nation-state
governance being adequate
and said we can't ever have that again
so then it created this in international
governance apparatus world
so i guess
what i'm saying is
that the solution
is not exponential tech
following the current path of what the
market incentivizes exponential tech to
do
market being a previous social tech
i would say that
exponential tech
if we look at different types of social
tech so let's just briefly look at
that democracy tried to do the emergent
order thing
right at least that's the story and
which is and this is why if you look
this important um part to build first
it's kind of doing it it's just doing it
poorly you're saying i mean that's it is
emergent order in some sense i mean
that's the hope of democracy versus
other
forms of government correct i mean i i
said at least the story because
obviously it didn't do it for women and
slaves early on it doesn't do it for all
classes equally et cetera
but the the idea of democracy is that
is participatory governance and so you
notice that the modern democracies
emerged out of
the european enlightenment and
specifically
because the idea that a lot of people
some huge number not a tribal number
huge number of anonymous people who
don't know each other are not
bonded to each other who believe
different things who grew up in
different ways can all work together to
make collective decisions well
that affect everybody and where some of
them will make compromises and the thing
that matters to them for what matters to
other strangers
that's actually wild like it's a wild
idea that that would even be possible
and it was kind of the result of this
high enlightenment idea
that we could all do the philosophy of
science
and we could all do the hegelian
dialectic those ideas had emerged right
and it was
that we we could all
so our choice making because we've said
a society is trying to coordinate choice
making the emergent order is the order
of our of the choices that we're making
not just the level of the individuals
but what groups of individuals
corporations nations states whatever do
our choices are based on our choice
making is based on our sense making and
our meaning making
our sense making is what do we believe
is happening in the world
and what do we believe the effects of a
particular thing would be our meaning
making is what do we care about
right our values generation what do we
care about that we're trying to move the
world in the direction of
if you ultimately are trying to move the
world in a direction that is
really really different than the
direction i'm trying to we have very
different values
we're gonna have a hard time and if you
think the world is a very different
world right if you
think that systemic racism is rampant
everywhere one of the worst problems and
i think it's not even a thing
if you think climate change is almost
existential and i think it's not even a
thing
we're gonna have a really hard time
coordinating and so we have to be able
to have shared sense making
of can we come to understand just what
is happening
together and then can we do shared
values generation okay maybe i'm
emphasizing a particular value more than
you but i can see how
i can take your perspective and i can
see how the thing that you value is
worth valuing
and i can see how it's affected by this
thing so can we take all the values and
try to come up with a proposition that
benefits all of them better
than the proposition i created just to
benefit these ones it harms the ones
that you
care about which is why you're opposing
my proposition yeah we don't even try in
the process of crafting a proposition
currently
to see and this is a reason that the
proposition when we vote on it gets half
the votes almost all the time
it almost never gets 90 of the votes is
because it benefits some things and
harms other things we can say oh theory
of trade-offs but we didn't even try to
say
could we see what everybody cares about
and see if there is a better solution
so how do we fix that try i i wonder is
it
is it as simple as the social technology
of education well no
it's that the proposition crafting and
refinement process has to be
key to a democracy or participatory
governance and it's not currently
but it's this isn't that the humans
creating that situation
so so one way there's two ways to fix
this
one is to fix the individual humans
which is the education early in life
and the second is to create somehow
systems that yeah
both so i understand the education part
but creating systems that's why that's
why i mentioned the technologies
is creating social networks essentially
yes that's actually necessary
okay so let's go to the first part and
then we'll come to the second part
so democracy emerged as an enlightenment
era idea
that we could all do a dialectic
and come to understand what other people
valued and so that we could
actually come up with a cooperative
solution rather than just
[ __ ] you we're gonna get our thing in
war right and that we could sense make
together we could all apply the
philosophy of science
and you weren't gonna stick to your guns
on what the speed of sound is if we
measured it and we found out what it was
and
there's a unifying element to the
objectivity in that way
and so this is why um i believe
jefferson said if you could give me a
perfect newspaper and a broken
government or
i'm paraphrasing or a broken government
perfect newspaper i wouldn't hesitate to
take the perfect newspaper because if
the people understand what's going on
they can make build a new government
if they don't understand what's going on
they can't possibly make good choices
and washington i'm paraphrasing again
first president said the number one aim
of the federal government should be
the comprehensive education of every
citizen in the science of government
science of government was the term of
art think about what that means right
science of government would be
game theory coordination theory history
wouldn't call game theory yet
history sociology economics right all
the things that lead
to how we understand human coordination
i think it's so profound
that he didn't say the number one aim of
the federal government is rule of law
and he didn't say it's protecting the
border from enemies because if the
number one aim was to protect the border
from enemies
it could do that as military
dictatorship quite effectively
and if the goal was rule of law it could
do it as a dictatorship
as a police state and so if the number
one goal is
anything other than the comprehensive
education of all the citizens in the
science of government it won't stay a
democracy long
you can see so both education and the
fourth estate
the fourth estate being the so education
can i make sense of the world am i
trained to make sense of the world the
fourth estate is what's actually going
on currently the news do i have good
unbiased information about it
those are both considered prerequisite
institutions for democracy to even be a
possibility
and then at the scale it was initially
suggested here the town hall was the key
phenomena
where there wasn't a special interest
group crafted a proposition and the
first thing i ever
saw was the proposition to know anything
about and i got to vote yes or no
it was in the town hall we all got to
talk about it and the proposition could
get crafted in real time
through the conversation which is why
there is that founding father statement
that that voting is the death of
democracy
voting fundamentally is polarizing the
population in some kind of sublimated
war
but and we'll do that as the last step
but what we want to do first is to say
how does the thing that you care about
that seems damaged by this proposition
how
could that turn into a solution to make
this proposition better
where this proposition still tends to
the thing it's trying to tend to
antennas to that better can we work on
this together
in the in a town hall we could have that
as the scale increased we lost the
ability to do that
now as you mentioned the internet could
change that the fact that
we had representatives that had to ride
a horse from one town hall to the other
one to see what the colony would do
um that we stopped having this kind of
developmental um propositional
development process
when the town hall ended the fact that
we have not used the internet to
recreate this is
somewhere between insane and
aligned with class interests i would
push back to say that the internet has
those things it just says a lot of other
things
i feel like the internet has places
where that encourage
synthesis of competing ideas
and sense making which is what we're
talking about
it's just that it's also flooded with a
bunch of other
systems that perhaps are out competing
it under current incentives
perhaps has to do with capitalism and
the market is there
linux is awesome right and wikipedia and
places where you have
and they have problems but places where
you have open source
sharing of information betting of
information towards collective building
is that building something like like
how much has that affected our court
systems or
our policing systems or our military
systems or first of all i think a lot
but not
not enough i i i think that's something
i told you offline yesterday's uh
perhaps that's a whole nother discussion
but i i don't think we're
quite quantifying the impact on the
world
of the positive impact of wikipedia
you said the policing the i mean i just
i just think the amount of um
empathy that could like knowledge
i think can't help but lead to
empathy just knowing okay
just knowing okay i'll give you some
pieces of information
knowing how many people died in various
awards that already that delta
when you have millions of people have
that knowledge it's like it's a little
like slap in the face like oh
like my boyfriend or girlfriend breaking
up with me
is not such a big deal when millions of
people were tortured
you know like just a little bit and when
a lot of people know that because of
wikipedia
or the effect there's second order
effect of wikipedia which is
it's not that necessarily people read
wikipedia it's like
youtubers who don't really
know stuff that well will
thoroughly read a wikipedia article and
create a compelling video describing
that wikipedia article that then
millions of people watch and they
understand that
holy [ __ ] a lot of there was such first
of all there was such a thing as world
war ii in world war one
okay like they can at least like learn
about it
they can learn about this was like
recent they can learn about slavery they
can learn about
all kinds of injustices in the world and
that i think has
a lot of effects to our to the way
whether you're a police officer a a
lawyer a judge
in the jury or just a regular
civilian citizen the way you approach
the every other communication you engage
in
even if the system of that communication
is very much flawed so i think there's a
huge positive effect on wikipedia
that's my case for wikipedia so you
should donate to wikipedia i mean i'm a
huge fan
but there's very few systems like it
which is sad to me
so i think it's it would be a useful
exercise
for any uh listener of the show
to really try to run the dialectical
synthesis process
with regard to a topic like this
and take the
techno concern perspective with regard
to
information tech that folks like tristan
harris
take and say what are all of the things
that are getting worse
and what and are any of them following
an exponential curve and how much worse
how quickly could that be
and then and do that fully without
mitigating it
then take the techno-optimist
perspective and see what things are
getting better
in a way that kurzweil or diamondus or
someone might do
and try to take that perspective fully
and say are some of those things
exponential
what could that portend and then try to
hold all that at the same time
and i think there are
ways in which depending upon the metrics
we're looking at
things are getting worse on exponential
curves and better on exponential curves
for different metrics at the same time
which which i hold is the
destabilization
of previous system and either an
emergence to a better system or
collapse to a lower order are both
possible
and so i want my optimism not to be
about my assessment
i want my assessment to be just as
[ __ ] clear as it can be
i want my optimism to be what inspires
the
solution process on that clear
assessment
so i never i never want to apply
optimism in the sense making right i
want to just
try to be clear if anything i want to
make sure that the
challenges are really well understood
but that's in service of an optimism
that there are good potentials even if i
don't know what they are that are worth
seeking
right there's kind of a there is a some
sense of optimism that's required to
even try to innovate really hard
problems
but then i want to take my pessimism and
red team my own optimism
to see is that solution not going to
work does it have second order effects
and then not get not get upset by that
because i
then come back to how to make it better
so just a relationship between optimism
and pessimism in the dialectic of how
they
how they can work so when i of course
we can say that wikipedia is a pretty
awesome example
of a thing we can look at the places
where it has limits or
has failed where
on a celebrity topic or a corporate
interest topic you can pay wikipedia
editors to
edit more frequently and various things
like that but you can also see where
there's a lot of information
that was kind of decentrally created
that is good information that is more
easily accessible to people than
everybody buying their own encyclopedia
britannica or walking down to the
library
and they can be updated in real time
faster
and i think you're very right that the
business model
is a big difference because
wikipedia is not a for-profit
corporation it is a
it's tending to the information commons
and it doesn't have
an agenda other than tending to the
information commons
and i think the two masters issue is a
tricky one when i'm trying to optimize
for very different kinds of things
where i have to sacrifice one for the
other and i can't find synergistic
satisfiers which one
and if i have a fiduciary responsibility
to shareholder
uh profit maximization and you know what
what does that
end up creating i think
the ad model that silicon valley took
um i think jaron lanier i don't know if
you've had him on the show but he has an
interesting assessment of
the nature of the ad model um silicon
valley
wanting to support capitalism and
entrepreneurs to make things but
uh also the belief that information
should be free
and also the network dynamics with the
more people you got on you got
increased value per user per capita as
more people got on so you didn't want to
do anything to slow the rate of adoption
some places actually you know paypal
paying people money to join the network
because the
uh value of the network would be there'd
be a metcalf-like dynamic proportional
to the square of the total number of
users
so um the ad model made sense of how do
we
make it free but also be a business get
everybody on
but not really thinking about what it
would mean to
and this is now the whole idea that if
you aren't paying for the product you
are the product
um if if they have a fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholder
maximize profit their customer is the
advertiser the user who it's being built
for is to
do behavioral mod for them for
advertisers that's a whole
different thing than that same type of
tech could have been if applied with a
different business model or a different
purpose
um i think there's
because facebook and
google and other information and
communication platforms end up
harvesting data about
user behavior that allows them to model
who the people are
in a way that gives them more sometimes
specific information and
behavioral information then
even a therapist or a doctor or a lawyer
or a priest might have in a different
setting
they basically are accessing privileged
information
there should be a fiduciary
responsibility
and in normal fiduciary law if there's
this principal agent thing if you are a
uh principal and i'm an agent on your
behalf i don't have a game theoretic
relationship with you right if you're
sharing something with me and i'm the
priest or i'm the therapist i'm never
going to use that information to try to
sell you a used car or
whatever the thing is but facebook is
gathering
massive amounts of privileged
information and using it to modify
people's behavior for a behavior that
they
didn't sign up for wanting the behavior
but what the corporation did
so i think this is an example of the
physical tech evolving in the context of
the previous social tech
where it's being shaped in particular
ways and here unlike wikipedia that
evolved for the
the information commons this evolved for
fulfilling particular agenda purpose
most people when they're on facebook
think it's just a tool that they're
using they don't realize it's an agent
right it is a corporation with a profit
motive and
and as i'm interacting with it it has a
goal for me different than my goal for
myself
and i might want to be on for a short
period of time its goal is maximize time
on site
and so there is a rivalry that is take
but where there should be a fiduciary
contract
i think that's actually a huge deal and
i think if we said could we apply
facebook like technology
to
uh develop people's
citizenry capacity right to develop
their personal health and well-being and
habits as well as their
um cognitive understanding the
complexity with which they can process
the health of their relationships
that would be amazing to start to
explore and this is now the thesis that
we started to discuss
before is every time there is a major
step function in the physical tech
it obsoletes the previous social tech
and the new social tech has to emerge
what i would say is that when we look at
the nation-state level of the world
today
the more top-down authoritarian
nation-states are
as the exponential text started to
emerge the digital technology started to
emerge
they were in a position for better
long-term planning
and better coordination and so the
authoritarian state started applying the
exponential tech
intentionally to make more effective
authoritarian states
and that's everything from like an
internet of things surveillance system
going into machine learning systems to
the sesame credit system to all those
types of things
and so they're upgrading their social
tech using the exponential tech
otherwise within a nation state like the
us but
democratic open societies this is the
countries the states are not
directing the technology in a way that
makes a better open society meaning
better emergent order
they're saying well the corporations are
doing that and the state is doing
the relatively little thing it would do
aligned with the previous corporate law
that no longer is relevant because there
wasn't fiduciary responsibility for
things like that there wasn't antitrust
because this creates functional
monopolies because of network dynamics
right where youtube has
more users than vimeo and every other
video player together amazon has a
bigger percentage of market share than
all of the other markets together you
get one
big dog per vertical because of network
effect which is a kind of organic
monopoly that the previous anti-trust
law didn't even have a place
that wasn't a thing anti-monopoly was
only something that emerged in the space
of government contracts
so um so what we see is the new
exponential technology is being directed
by authoritarian nation states to make
better authoritarian nation states and
by corporations to make more powerful
corporations
the more powerful corporations when we
think about the scottish enlightenment
when the idea of markets was being
advanced the modern kind of ideas of
markets
the biggest corporation was tiny
compared to what the biggest corporation
today is so the asymmetry of it relative
to people was tiny
and the asymmetry now in terms of the
total technology it employs total amount
of money total amount of information
processing
is so many orders of magnitude and
rather than there be demand for an
authentic thing
that creates a basis for supply as
supply started to get way more
coordinated and powerful and the demand
wasn't coordinated because you don't
have a labor union of all the customers
working together
but you do have a coordination on the
supply side supply started to recognize
that it could manufacture demand
it could make people want [ __ ] that they
didn't want before that maybe wouldn't
increase their happiness
in a meaningful way might increase
addiction addiction is a very good way
to manufacture demand
and so as soon as manufactured demand
started
through this is the cool thing and you
have to have it for status or whatever
it is
the intelligence of the market was
breaking now it's no longer a collective
intelligence system that is up
regulating
real desire for things that are really
meaningful you're able to hijack
the lower angels of our nature rather
than the higher ones the addictive
patterns
drive those and have people watch it
that doesn't actually make them happy or
make the world better
and so we really also have to we have to
update our theory of markets because
behavioral econ showed that homo
economicus the rational actor is not
really a thing
but particularly at greater and greater
scale can't really be a thing
voluntarism isn't a thing or if my corp
if my company doesn't want to advertise
on facebook i just will lose to the
companies that do because that's where
all the [ __ ] attention is
and so then i can say it's voluntary but
it's not really if there's a functional
monopoly
same if i'm gonna sell on amazon or
things like that so
what i would say is these corporations
are becoming
more powerful than nation states in some
ways
and
they are also debasing the integrity
of the nation states the open societies
so the democracies are getting weaker
as a result of exponential tech and the
kind of new
tech companies that are kind of a new
feudalism tech feudalism because
it's not a democracy inside of a tech
company or the supply and demand
relationship
when you have manufactured demand and
kind of monopoly type functions
and so we have basically a new feudalism
controlling exponential tech and
authoritarian nation states controlling
it and those attractors are both shitty
and so i'm interested in the application
of exponential tech
to making better social tech that makes
emergent order possible
and within that emergent order can bind
and direct the exponential tech
in fundamentally healthy not x-risk
oriented directions
i think the relationship of social tech
and physical tech can make it
i think we can actually use the physical
tech to make better social tech but it's
not
given that we do if we don't make better
social tech
then i think the physical tech empowers
really shitty social tech that it's not
a world that we want
i don't know if it's a road we want to
go down but i tend to believe that the
market
will create exactly the thing you're
talking about which i feel like there's
a lot of money to be made
in creating a
social tech that creates a better
citizen
it creates a better human being
the this this uh the the your
description of facebook and so on
which is a system that creates addiction
which manufacturers demand
is not obviously inherently
the consequence of the markets like i
feel like that's the the first stage of
us
like baby deer trying to figure out how
to use the internet i i feel like
there's much more money to be made
with something that creates
compersion and love honestly i mean i i
really
from we can have this i can make the
business case for it i don't know
i don't think we want to really have
that discussion but don't do you have
some hope that that's the case
and what i guess if not then how do we
fix the system of markets that work so
well for
the united states for so long like i
said every social tech worked for a
while like tribalism worked
well for two or three hundred thousand
years i think
social tech has to keep evolving the
social technologies
with which we organize and coordinate
our behavior have to keep evolving as
our physical tech does
so i think the thing that we call
markets
of course we can try to say oh even
biology runs on markets and
but the thing that we call markets
the underlying theory homo economicus
demand
driving supply that thing broke it broke
with
scale in particular um and a few other
things
so it needs updated in a really
fundamental way
um i think there's something even deeper
than making money happening
that it in some ways will obsolete money
making
i think capitalism is not about business
so if you think about business i'm gonna
produce a good or a service that people
want and
bring it to the market so that people
get access to that good or service
that's the world of business
but that's not capitalism capitalism is
the
management and allocation of capital
which
financial services was a tiny percentage
of the total market has become a huge
percentage of the total market it's a
different creature
so if i was in business and i was
producing a good or service and i was
saving up enough money that i started to
be able to invest that money and gain
interest or
do things like that i could start
realizing i'm making more
money on my money than i'm making on
producing the goods and services
so i stop even paying attention to goods
and services and start paying attention
to
making money on money and how do i
utilize capital to create more capital
and capital gives me more optionality
because i can buy anything with it than
a particular good or service that only
some people want
capitalism
more capital ended up meaning more
control
i could put more people under my
employment i could buy larger pieces of
land novel access to resource mines and
put more technology under my employment
so it meant increased agency and also
increased control
i think attentionalism is even more
powerful
so rather than enslave people
where the people kind of always want to
get away and put in
the least work they can there's a way in
which economic servitude was just more
profitable than slavery
right have the people work even harder
voluntarily because they want to get
ahead
and nobody has to be there to whip them
or control them or whatever
[Music]
this is a cynical take but a meaningful
take
um so people
so capital ends up being a way to
influence human behavior right
and yet where people still feel free
in some meaningful way they they're not
feeling like
they're going to be punished by the
state if they don't do something it's
like punished by the market via
homelessness or
something but the market is this
invisible thing i can't put an agent on
so it feels like free
and so if
if you want to affect people's behavior
and still have them feel free capital
ends up being a way to
do that but i think affecting their
attention is even deeper
because if i can affect their attention
i can
both affect what they want and what they
believe and what they feel
and we statistically know this very
clearly facebook has done studies that
based on
changing the feed it can change beliefs
emotional dispositions etc
and so i think there's a way that the
the harvest and directing of attention
is even a more powerful system than
capitalism it
is effective in capitalism to generate
capital but i think it also generates
influence beyond what capital can do and
so
do we want to have some
groups utilizing
that type of tech to direct other
people's attention if so
um towards what
towards what metrics of what a good
civilization and good human life would
be
what's the oversight process what is the
transparency i can i can
answer all the things you're mentioning
uh i i can build i guarantee you if i
i'm not such a lazy ass uh i'll be part
of the many people doing this
as transparency and control i'll get to
giving control to individual people okay
so maybe
the corporation has
coordination on its goals that all of
its customers or users together don't
have so there's some asymmetry where
it's
uh asymmetry of its goals but maybe i
could actually help
all of the customers to coordinate
almost like a labor union or whatever by
informing and educating them adequately
about the effects the externalities on
them this is not
toxic waste going into the ocean of the
atmosphere it's their their minds their
beings their families their
relationships
um such that they will in group change
their
behavior and um i think
the idea one way of saying what you're
saying i think is that you think that
you can rescue
homo economicus from
uh the rational actor that will pursue
all the goods and services and choose
the best one at the best price the kind
of rand
von mises hayek that you can rescue that
from dan ariely and behavioral econ that
says that's actually not how people make
choices they make it based on status
hacking
largely whether it's good for them or
not in the long term
and the large asymmetric corporation can
run
propaganda in narrative warfare that
hits people's status buttons and their
limbic hijacks and their lots of other
things in ways that
they can't even perceive that are
happening
they're not paying attention to that the
site is employing psychologists and
split testing and whatever else
so you're saying i think we can recover
homo economics
and not just through a singles like
mechanism technology there's there's the
uh not to keep mentioning the guy but
platforms like
joe rogan and so on that that make
help make viral the ways
that the education of negative
externalities can become viral
in this world so interestingly
i actually agree with you that
got them that four and a half hours in
that we can tech can do some good all
right well see
what you're talking about is the
application of tech here broadcast
tech where you can speak to a lot of
people and that's not going to be
strong enough because the different
people need spoken too differently which
means it has to be different voices to
get amplified to those audiences more
like facebook's tech but nonetheless
we'll start with broadcast tech
plants the first seed and then the word
of mouth is a powerful thing
you need to do the first broadcast
shotgun and then
it like lands or catapulted whatever i
don't know what the right weapon is
but then it just spreads to word of
mouth through all kinds of tech
including facebook so let's come back to
the fundamental
thing the fundamental thing is we want
to kind of order at various scales
from the conflicting parts of our self
actually having more
harmony than they might have
to uh family extended family local
all the way up to global we want
emergent order where our
choices have
more alignment right we want that to be
emergent rather than imposed
or rather than we want fundamentally
different things or make totally
different sense of the world where
warfare of some kind becomes the only
solution emerging order requires us
in our choice making requires us being
able to have
related sense making and related meaning
making processes
can we apply digital technologies and
exponential tech in general
to try to increase the capacity to do
that where the technology called a town
hall the social tech that we all get
together and talk obviously is very
scale limited
and it's also oriented to geography
rather than networks of aligned interest
can we build new better versions of
those types of things
and going back to the idea that a
democracy or participatory governance
depends upon comprehensive education in
the science of government which includes
being able to understand
things like asymmetric information
warfare on the side of governments and
how the people can
organize adequately can you utilize some
of the technologies now
to be able to support increased
comprehensive education
of the people and maybe comprehensive
informedness
so both fixing the decay in both
education and the fourth estate that
have happened so the people can start
self-organizing to then
influence the corporations the
nation-states
to do different things and or build new
ones themselves
yeah fundamentally that's the thing that
has to happen we
the exponential tech gives us a novel
problem landscape that the world never
had
the nuke gave us a novel problem
landscape and so that required
this whole bretton woods world the
exponential tech gives us novel problem
landscape
our existing problem-solving processes
aren't doing a good job
we have had more countries get nukes we
haven't nuclear deep proliferation we
haven't achieved any of the un's
sustainable development goals
we haven't kept any of the new
categories of tech from making arms
races so our global coordination is not
adequate to the problem landscape
so we need fundamentally better problem
solving processes a market or a state is
a problem-solving process we need better
ones it can do
the speed and scale of the current
issues right now speed is one of the
other big things
is that by the time we regulated ddt out
of existence or
cigarettes not for people under 18
they'd already killed so many people
and we let the market do the thing but
as
elon has made the point that won't work
for ai by the time we recognize
afterwards that we have an autopoetic ai
that's a problem you won't be able to
reverse it that there's a number of
things that
when you're dealing with tech that is
either self-replicating
and disintermediates humans to keep
going doesn't need humans to keep going
or you have tech that just has um
exponentially fast effects
your regulation has to come early it
can't come
after the effects have happened the
negative effects have happened if
because the negative x could be too big
too quickly
so we basically need new problem solving
processes that do
better at being able to internalize
externality
solve the problems on the right time
scale and the right geographic
scale and those new processes to not be
imposed have to emerge from people
wanting them
and being able to participate in their
development which is what i would call
kind of a new cultural enlightenment a
renaissance that has to happen
where people start understanding the new
power
that exponential tech offers the way
that it is actually damaging
current governance structures that we
care about
and creating an x-risk landscape but
could also be redirected
towards more protopic purposes and then
saying how do we rebuild new social
institutions what are adequate social
institutions
where we can do participatory governance
at scale and time
and how can the people actually
participate to build those things
i the the solution that i see working
requires a process like that
and the result maximizes love so
again elon must be right that love is
the answer
you